- You get two options:
stay patient or quit.
Which was more
attractive, George?
("Monday To Monday" by Saba)
- Saba, mother fuckers.
I've been telling you.
Hey guys.
I have to do this quick call but
I wanted to just state something
that's happening on Insta.
There's so much growth for me on
Instagram and I'm concerned that
are people getting confused
and I don't think I'm worth
listening to or being paid
attention to because I have
funny quotes or inspiring quotes
or inspiring one
minute clips on Instagram.
It's what I'm saying,
it's what I'm doing.
("Sheets" by Alex Harris)
People that are giving
feedback right now,
both pro and con,
please don't get confused.
Obviously, I communicate,
I'm a human being,
this is about what I'm
fucking doing 18 hours a day.
Not what I'm posting
three times a day on Instagram.
It's the execution.
Come on YouTube live.
Give it to me.
I'm live but
I'm not really live.
- [DRock] Nothing?
- It's trying. It says
I'm live but I'm not.
Can you guys hear me?
Damn.
I love this.
Alright guys, I'm
gonna figure out how
to get a better connection.
I will definitely
be back on this.
We will definitely do this.
Life will happen, I promise.
This isn't, I'm not magic or
special or anything in how
clever my pictures
is on Instagram.
I'm trying to be special on
the fact that I'm out-executing
strategically and then putting
in the actual work to build
businesses that come from
merit and a good place and bring
enormous value to the people
within them and the people that
watch how it's done so that they
can map it and do it themselves.
I don't think I should have any
guests on #AskGaryVee any more.
- [DRock] Was there
hate on it too much?
- People just get
upset that I interrupt and
I think they're right.
I'm just not
willing to not be me.
Which is fine, can't
do everything perfectly.
- [Trouty] You've always
done that back to
Wine Library TV days.
People got upset then.
- Yeah. I'm not good at it.
The funniest part is
I don't do anything perfectly.
I do a couple things solidly.
- [Trouty] The Jewel one--
- The Jewel one
I did really good.
- [Trouty] She can hold her own.
- [DRock] That was good.
- No, no Tony could too.
Like everybody can.
Seth Godin can too.
The Jewel one I really tried.
I really tried on Tony.
Tony had to go and so
I want to move it along.
It's how my brain works.
By the way, there's plenty of
people that email me that love
it because they don't like
listening to podcasts where you
let the person answer for 700
years and everybody knows what
the fuck they're saying.
Sorry.
- [Trouty] You
always know, right?
That's what you do.
- But I don't want to.
People are very sad.
Actually that's it.
I'm only doing guests.
You know what?
I'm gonna triple down.
I'm not even gonna try
any more to be somewhat.
You think I'm interrupting now?
Wait, 'til episode
300 mother fuckers.
I'm gonna have 15 of the most
famous fuckin' people you ever
saw and they're not
gonna say a fuckin' word.
So this isn't
about my fuckin' post.
It's about my execution.
("Sheets" by Alex Harris)
We need to create
content and distribute it.
It's not super complicated.
You know, it's just
fucking that's it, you know?
Airport life.
Is it sad that I'm
so cozy in an airport?
Like feels like home.
What do we have?
We have Naples, we have
Atlanta, we have St. Louis,
we have Austin, we got New York.
- Sorry, I know you probably get
this every single hour and it's
probably really cool for you.
- [Gary] It is
really cool for me.
What's your name?
- I'm just scrolling
Instagram and I'm like no way.
- [Gary] (laughs)
What's your name, man?
- Liam. Nice to meet you.
- [Gary] Liam, thanks
for saying hello, brother.
- Yeah, absolutely.
Do you mind if I
get a picture with you?
- [Gary] No, no, no problem.
- [Liam] Thank you very much.
- [Gary] My pleasure, man.
- [Liam] I really
appreciate that.
- Real pleasure.
- [Liam] Thanks
for what you do.
- [Gary] Thanks, my man.
- It's inspiring.
- [Gary] Thank you, brother.
("Sheets" by Alex Harris)
I'm super excited to
be down here in Florida.
Pretty epic
dinner event tonight.
Trouty's here.
But you already know what
because I'm sure you'll show
that goofy thing he did.
Should be a pretty epic night.
Lot of business development.
Pretty senior stuff.
Should be really cool.
Friday, really
looking forward to it.
This Friday SXSW,
my tenth anniversary of
going to that conference.
The place where a
lot of this happened.
Where I met a lot of the people
that changed the course
of my professional career.
Really got into
the Web 2.0 movement.
Giving a Q&amp;A keynote.
So instead of pontificating just
rolling in saying come if you
know my spiel, fire
away with your questions.
Really looking forward to it.
Should be a lot of fun.
And we'll see what comes of it.
Really I'm not sure
what's gonna happen.
I'm counterpunch.
Sure, it's the
same old stuff, right?
People looking
for permission to go.
for that extra push,
that extra motivation.
Some people looking
for that subtle detail,
that secret. Here's a secret.
It's four letters,
W-O-R-K.
That's the fucking secret.
That will always be the secret.
It's the only
thing you can control.
Your talent is your talent,
you can only maximize it.
And so, it should be fun.
I'm really
looking forward to it.
South-by a good mix of
corporate Fortune 500 people,
entrepreneurs, startup,
hard-core tech founders,
media, journalists.
Real hodgepodge, real kind of
cool melting pot of different
people with different agendas,
different strategies
so looking forward to it.
For all of you that are
going to SXSW my one tip is
to just say hello, right?
Conferences are
about networking.
The content you can
watch the next day or follow
the Twitter stream, right?
But saying hello and sparking
up a relationship is something
that's not replica-table.
Genuinely, may be the only
time you ever get to do it.
So whether it's somebody admire
or you're just standing in line
and you don't know the person,
you never know if that person is
the key to your next step.
I think a lot of people think
information is the unlock to
next chapters in their career
but I find that it's the people
that are often the
actual unlock and so a really
easy tactic, say hello.
Be warm and kind and network.
I know some people have anxiety
with that or this and that.
I'm empathetic to that
but I would highly recommend
trying to break it.
If you're going to a
conference like South-by
the networking is the ROI.
Good afternoon Instagram.
How are you?
I hope you're well.
Be okay after
that tremendous drop.
("Up In Smoke" by
Andrew Triple A)
How do you stay
patient when building a brand?
By realizing, George,
there's no choice.
Patience (laughs),
patience is the only option.
Like you have two options:
stay patient or quit.
Which one's more
attractive, George?
What up Ray Franklin?
Good to see you?
What do you think about
Brandon Marshall
not being a Jet?
I'm sad.
Brandon's a good friend.
He's a really good player
but the Jets need to rebuild.
We need to go 0 and 16.
You know?
Just the way it is.
Hope to see you in ATL as well.
ATL's tomorrow.
Atlanta tomorrow and
then tomorrow night New York.
Then St. Louis,
then Austin.
Busy.
No more Udemy courses.
I only did that
for a book promotion.
I'm just putting out content.
You don't need my Udemy
courses, just watch DailyVee.
Watch what I do,
don't listen to what I say.
Watch what I do, don't
listen to what I say.
Watch what I do,
don't listen to what I say.
Watch what I do.
("Up In Smoke" by
Andrew Triple A)
There's all sorts of versions.
The common one is airport Gary,
the rare one is
business attire Gary.
But pretty big
meeting for us tonight.
Very focal for the
strategy of the agency
and so I'm excited.
Like to spiffy up
once in a while.
DRock, you're impressed, right?
It's rare. Not too shabby.
- [DRock] Rare.
- Anyway, (laughs), rare.
Rare, limited edition suit Gary.
Anyway, keep hustling everybody.
Hope you have a great day.
Talk to you soon and
actually, you know what?
This is not the end of it.
We're gonna do some live tonight
back at the crib so we'll get a
little more footage.
See ya.
("Up In Smoke"
by Andrew Triple A)